SHELBY STANGA: What the hell is
that doing up here on my
property?
Huh?
It look like a damn junkyard.
I pull up and there's a
damn RV sitting on my land
like a big pile of junk.
Did you remember what I
told y'all about people
dropping [bleep] off here?
The gate was wide open.
I don't-- I thought
you left the gate open.
Ain't this a [bleep].
You can't get your
work done there.
Got people dropping junk off.
They think it's a damn dump.
It might look like a dump.
But it ain't.
You know that?
NARRATOR: While Shelby
was living off the grid,
the locals made his
landing the family
neighborhood garbage dump.
And some folks
haven't stopped yet.
I'm going to take the
stuff that's good off of it.
Someone leaves stuff on my
land, I'm taking the stuff.
How do you open this up now?
NARRATOR: Now this may look
like a five ton rust bucket.
But everyone knows the swamp
man has a knack for turning
trash into treasure.
So Shelby will put the
order on a brief hold
as he raids his
shiny new piggy bank.
One of them good ones
there for a farmer.
Already get in a high
tax bracket already, man.
NARRATOR: And he's
going to crack it open
and take every last penny.
A TV that plugs into
a cigarette lighter.
I've never seen
one of them before.
I sure would like a TV.
Got my own TV!
What is this thing?
Oh, man.
A bed.
Oh, here we go!
What the hell?
Charcoal lighter fluid
for the charcoal.
Boy, this RV is
like a gold mine.
I mean, totally wrong.
You see anything you want,
put it in your pocket.
[dog barking]
Where you at?
This thing worth a bunch
of money on the damn eBay.
WOMAN: Ain't you
have one of those?
- Here.
- Holy crap.
Put that outside.
That will be $500 smackaronis.
Oh my, we used to play
this at my grandma's house
all the time.
That's valuable stuff.
It might be better than logging.
It's better than
"The Price Is Right".
Here.
[cash register sound]
Give that to the kids.
OK.
Better go on the
wall, like Bob Barker.
I don't know what that is.
I never seen one of them.
What is that?
That's a Pop-A-Plate.
What does that mean?
You stick your plates up here.
Come on.
Like this.
Ah hah.
Oh, man.
Got to have that.
Take that off.
[cash register sound]
- Yeah.
That is cool
Oh man.
Look at here.
Man, that's $400,
$500 that's in there.
[cash register sound]
NARRATOR:
WOMAN: The brokedown RVs
turned out to be a cash cow.
[cow mooing]
And Shelby is milking
it for all it's worth.
I got everything
I need out of it.
Ain't nothing left.
We're doing good now.
WOMAN: Slowly but
surely, the swamp man's
getting back on track.
Get that high tax bracket.
Ha!
Here we go!